ein junger mann sagte alle frauen sind
dumm ein älterer herr hörte dies und
sagte ihm das nicht gemacht und das gibt
leute in dem moment in dem ihr dieses
video schaut passiert etwas in dieser
welt vor unser aller augen wie alle
schauen hin aber keiner unter dem was
dagegen
die rede ist von instagram trend und
genau deswegen weil man dann einfach
nicht mehr länger zuschauen kann man
kann natürlich länger daneben stehen und
einfach nichts machen machen wir jetzt
dieses video um uns über den humor den
es teilweise auf instagram gibt lustig
zu machen denn da sieht man teilweise
echt davor und denkt sich denn ab jetzt
habe ich gerade mein leben zu beenden
der wird zwar so schlecht ist natürlich
keine verallgemeinerung natürlich gibt
es auch gute witze auf instagram und
natürlich ganz wichtig ist humor
verschieden vielleicht finden auch
manche von euch die witze die wir gleich
zeigen lustig aber es gibt einfach
sachen wo man ja wo wir uns denken so
alter finden leute das lustig ist doch
nur noch peinlich wir schauen uns heute
diesen sehr speziellen humor an machen
uns vielleicht lustig und linke so
das finde ich gut und zwar max ein paar
post ausgesucht wo er sich gedacht hat
das war so lustig die sache bringen mich
um die schau ist alles okay war aber was
ist das hier witzige bilder deutsch ist
die seite wir haben hier ein bild von
ihr sie finde ich jetzt erstmal so nicht
mehr dramatisch warum daumen ist das ist
ich bin mir sicher
vielleicht stecken der witzige bilder
deutsche macht hier sind jungs die seit
am arsch ich drei mal dein handy um dann
lesen wir mal unten
kannst dir zurück drehen wollte dich nur
beschäftigen und das doppel konkret
einfach so ein 2011 mai die alten noch
keine kies das sind die momente die sie
morgens im bett liegt mir das anschauen
und erst mal so richtig richtig hardcore
nicht lachst kann man das nicht immer
mehrere wäre ich weiß nicht ob das neben
rabatten witzige bilder deutsch
das durchgehend deutsch dass das
deutsche oder es ist ein bild ist kein
video ist es witzig das war eben erst
mal der einstieg aber wir haben noch
einige saftige rest zwei arten von
männern ok wat ist es wieder witzige
bilder deutsch also muss ist muss wieder
lustig sein eigentlich bezahlt auch mein
land da drüben sind cupcakes und blumen
und hier sind flasche whisky nyc wenn du
verstehst verstehst du es besser kannst
nicht leiden
ich verstehe nicht worauf worauf will
dieses bild hinaus ich bin anfangs gar
nicht in der lage ist zu verstehen
naja guck mal als wollten sie sagen herr
kämpfer bund like wenn du das verstehst
braunschweig 1 1 mike wenn du verstehst
oder einfach leid wenn du gerade garten
du kannst auch einfach so einfach
komplett schwarz machen und so in die in
die mitte weiß like schreiben und so
genau
die kids allerdings sind auch
zwölfjährige fenster doch die zwölf
wegen von früher sind es längst die
früher bei rund 1017 war vor ein paar
monaten krass und heute ist mal sicher
früher haben zwölfjährige noch dämonen
bekämpft früher haben zwölf jahre dass
ich noch in die unterwelt begeben und
das ein oder andere alien wesen auch
bekämpft und schwarze magie auch
eingesetzt heutzutage sind sie einfach
nur noch sehr erfolgreich und verdienen
100.000 euro pro jahr dazu muss man
jetzt sagen hier ist auch ein guter witz
der stelle
was ich besonders gut finde ist links
like jeder kennt die like funktion bei
instagram rechts herz das geht halt
nicht besser
wie kriege ich möglich wieder likes auf
dieses bild oh ja ich glaube die haben
was übersehen
hab gelacht habt kein lacht flash also
das ist gestohlen von hab kein lacht
okay kann ja verstehen dass bei so einem
guten witz man noch nicht abstoßend der
ja wie viele stand ist dass man sich
über den sturz nach unten schon 20 euro
dann muss man kurz mal nicht fenster von
außen anschauen gemacht hast das ist
wieder dieses selben schema du das nie
aber mit ganz essen dann 70 dem motto
zeig deine reaktion
er weiß ebro bitte gebilde deutsch du
bist schwer krank dann spielt es ist ein
krankenhausarzt du dir deine mutter
übrigens du hast tripper ein sächsischer
keine reaktion
jetzt festhalten wer jetzt ist eine
witzige werde jetzt extrem witzig dass
auch für einen besonders mannschaft
erstmal an er aber eher fast den anderen
[Applaus]
hatte dann 15 mal eine reaktion
gras ist wird nicht von sting ist wie
zur hölle soll ich meine reaktion
anzeigen wenn nicht dasteht wie ich
machen so ja das wifi ist er jetzt
welche reaktion
man weiß es nicht weiter geht's mit
dies war mein video wenn deine freundin
nur das eine will
achtung du musst dich festhalten ich
bewundere dich auch das serviceteam
kann's aber und ich hing öffentlichkeit
gibt es jedoch nicht und du weißt es
kann auf mich zurück verfolgt werden
dass das ist viel zu gefährlich ist du
dir sicher dass du sie ihr geben rät
einmal das schlimmste die wir jemals
hatten
aber was ist das jetzt noch mal genau
irgendwie hat man glaube ich zu einem
schlüssel
okay die einzige erklärung hierfür ist
er hat das video geschnitten und hatten
bis hin zu vergessen die wo der visconti
harald lappessen sehen das hat 370.000
aufrufe das ist kein witz die einzige
erklärung die ich habe ist das ist
irgendwie eine bibliothek skaten
bibliotheksausweis die stets auch ne
oder sie meinte sein büchereiausweis
ayala smiley land das ich haben wir eine
person die das ist nicht mit einem
getränkemarkt seit dem rennen kommen wir
die hat nämlich das ja nur ein
erfolgsrezept
schauen wir mal du ziehst mal wieder
durch frauen im sommer wenn sie ihre
tagen tage haben wenn die tage deiner
freundin vorbei sind wenn jungs ihre
tage hätten frauen in der beziehung wenn
sie ihre tage haben frauen im sommer
wenn sie ihre tage haben zwei er hat
irgendwie so ein seltsames fetisch für
frauen ihre tage haben die comedy
[Musik]
und also bekannt für wenn frauen digital
geholfen auch kann für wenn frauen ihre
tage beim fahrradfahren auf einer
einspurigen landstraße abenteuer greifen
wenn frauen ihre tage haben nachdem sie
einen butterkuchen gegessen haben aus
der sicht eines spanischen ausländers
der mit zwölf noch in syrien gewohnt hat
eine million aufrufe und jetzt hat max
noch einen länger geschickt hat er mir
schon mal in auszügen gezeigt das ist
halt nicht wenn ich mal komme dieses
quasi das ist schlüsse das ist so eine
motivation video oder so ein lied all
the best trend videos hat glaube ich
fast eine million abonnenten
bildunterschrift ein junger mann sagt er
alle frauen sind um ein älterer herr
hase dies und sagte ihm ein junger mann
sagte alle frauen sind dumm ein älterer
herr hörte dies und sagte ihm wenn das
video schon so traurige musik und wenn
sie so ein bild von seinem alten mann
aus und bild von manaus mittleren osten
ganz gefährlich leute kann gut sein dass
es gleich richtig
die ausgangssituation ein junger mann
sagte ein alter mann antwortete das ist
so kannst du die geschichte von das
wahrscheinlich irgendwo irgendwie seiten
dicker bitte denkt ja irgend so eine
story aus die halbwegs emotional ist und
hast du 20
die größte dummheit einer frau was einen
unwissenden und undankbaren wie dich
neun monate in ihrem bauch zu tragen und
dich zwei jahren von ihrer milch zu
speisen achtung trommelwirbel und das
nur um 20 jahre darauf zu warten dass
ein esel wie du groß wird und andere
frauen zu belegen jetzt leike dieses
video werde auch du diesen älteren mann
recht gibst mir ich muss ganz frei muss
ganz kurz das video leiten er sorry ich
geb diesem elternrecht die ja meist
nicht mal im spaß aber ich weiß was er
kurz eine million auf diese story stehen
von vorn hinten danach dass er gesagt
hat ich muss mir irgendwas ausdenken wo
man vielleicht sagen kann borja der hat
recht und dann so aber ich hab nicht nur
drei minuten zeit sich aber nicht
wirklich etwas auszudenken deswegen
warte okay ein junger mal ok aber was
ist etwas der plot ist was ist das
bewegen der ok ein alter mann sagt was
dazu egal ich will mich umbringen was
mir am meisten daran weh tut ist einfach
wie billig das gemacht ist
ich könnte stundenlang übernehme sagt
natürlich gemacht und das ergibt doch
[Gelächter]
die ist ein mensch mit verstand gourmet
macht ein junger mann
soja für diesen von ein junger mann ging
aber die straße und sagte [ __ ] eine
alte frau sagte warum sagst du das teil
dieses video wenn du auch so denkt wie
die seite frau leute das was von diesem
video ich finde gerade das letzte hat
gezeigt wie auch mäßig schlecht dieser
instagram crash ist ich kann nicht
verstehen warum ist eine million aufrufe
hat deswegen vielleicht max abonnieren
es in der beschreibung verlinkt weil
kann sein dass ich einfach macht's gut
und wird so leicht mit diesen seiten